Speaker 1: Let's start today with Ron DeSantis.
Now, if you listen to our episodes or watch the
videos a day or two later than we publish them,
we may already know the answer to the question
of whether Ron DeSantis will or will not enter the
2024 Republican primary race. Speculation is that
he is going to announce if he will announce as
soon as this week. But extraordinarily fascinating
is a new report from The New York Times that
privately, one of the ways that Ron DeSantis has
been trying to convince major Republican donors to
support him instead of Donald Trump is by telling
the donors that Trump cannot win in 2024. Now, the
interesting thing about this is that in a strictly
mathematical sense, based on polling, DeSantis may
actually be making the most fact based argument
that could be made about why someone would choose
DeSantis over Trump in the Republican primary,
even if they are sort of MAGA people. And we're
going to look at that polling. But it's not wrong
in a strictly factual sense for DeSantis to
be making this argument. But is this the way
to project strength to those who are saying,
well, we've got the former President Trump,
but maybe I want something different so I
could support someone else? Does it project
strength for DeSantis case to be Trump can't Win.
So give me money instead. We look at this report,
Biden and me. DeSantis privately tells
donors Trump can't win. Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida all but declared his
presidential candidacy Thursday afternoon,
telling donors and supporters on a call that
only three credible candidates were in the
race and that only he would be able to win both
the Republican primary and the general election.
Quote, You have basically three people at this
point that are credible in this whole thing,
Biden, Trump, and me. And I think of those three
to have a chance to get elected president Biden
and me based on all the data in the swing
states, which is not great for the former
president and probably insurmountable because
people aren't going to change their view of him.
This is correct. It's such a unique situation
in which we find ourselves right now. I believe
that DeSantis is right When we look at
new and recent polling of different kinds,
you see that. Let's see which of these are the
most relevant to what we're talking about. There
is a Harris X poll, which is done in partnership
with Harvard. If you look at that one, Biden,
DeSantis are even. But Biden is losing to Trump
by seven. That's an outlier in which Trump does
better against Biden than DeSantis. But you
look at most polling and Biden does better
against Trump than he does against Ron DeSantis,
for example. You have Biden actually, you know,
in. Is this turning around? I'm now looking. The
last I looked at this was Friday. There's a bunch
of new polling which actually says that Biden
is doing better against the Santos than Trump.
So if the polling is turning around, maybe this
is wrong. But historically, Biden has done better
against Trump than DeSantis. So let's imagine
that these last couple of polls are outliers
and don't represent the broader picture. DeSantis
isn't wrong in saying that if we were to get to
a general election matchup, I do better against
Biden than Trump. Let's imagine that that's true.
But this is a very weak case to be making. This is
a sign of DeSantis insecurity and fear of Trump,
which is very clear, which is to skip and
just say, if we get to November, I do better.
Whether or not that's true, because DeSantis
doesn't really know how to run against Trump.
So these are the sorts of things he's relegated to
telling donors, Well, it's not about I'm going to
do better with X Group in the South or whatever
the case may be. It's Trump can't actually win,
and I could. So the idea is undermine Trump in
front of donors behind closed doors, appeal to
the donors and say to them, You need a more viable
alternative. And I guess it's me. I don't know
that this is an effective strategy to win the
Republican primary. That's the critical thing
to understand. Even if DeSantis is right, he does
better against Biden than Trump or if he's wrong.
This is not a strategy that is going to propel the
Santos to winning the Republican nomination, which
he has to do first. Because when you look at the
strategy of DeSantis on policy, on the one hand,
during Trump's presidency, DeSantis was a major
Trump brown noser and sycophant. Santos echoed
some of Trump's lies about the election. DeSantis
echoed much of what Trump was saying about COVID,
even though now, in retrospect, they're pretending
that they were really far apart on COVID. But you
look at immigration, you look at voting rights.
Banning books that criticize Trump from public
schools. You look at all these things this long
period of time, they were in lockstep. And in
retrospect, now both are drawing distinctions and
trying to criticize. The other is saying they went
the wrong way. I now represent the heart of the
Republican Party. That doesn't seem like it's
going to convince MAGA people to abandon Trump
and support DeSantis. And that's what this is all
about. I'm getting so wound up, I just punched my
microphone. I apologize to people listening with
headphones. At the end of the day, this is a math
or maths problem. DeSantis, even if he gets all
of the current non-Trump vote, cannot get to 50%
in the Republican primary. And so when you hear
DeSantis behind closed doors telling donors Trump
can't actually beat Biden or whatever the case
may be, the donors, if they're at all connected to
reality, should be looking at DeSantis and saying,
Listen, Ron Meatball, whatever they call him at
this point, even if we believe you, that you're
the guy that can beat Biden. This isn't going
to help you beat Trump, who already has 55, 56,
57% of the primary. What exactly are you going to
do to turn Trump voters to your side? And DeSantis
has no answer to that whatsoever. So DeSantis is
doing the thing that oftentimes primary candidates
who will lose are going to do. Look at Nikki
Haley, Nikki Haley, instead of going after Trump,
other than to say I'm from a different generation,
basically, I'm younger and I'm a woman.
Nikki Haley has been mostly criticizing Joe Biden.
That's a loser's strategy. You're not explaining
how you win the primary when you just say, here
are all the problems with Joe Biden. Trump spends
all day criticizing Joe Biden. It's not going to
convince Republican voters. So I'm as curious as
anybody else to see what happens if and when
DeSantis enters this race that maybe today,
that may be tomorrow, or he may say if if better
judgment gets to him, I can't win this thing. I'm
going to wait until 2028. I struggle to imagine
DeSantis gets away from polling 20% and saying,
maybe I could double it, maybe I could triple
it. So we will know much more very soon. But in
the meantime, DeSantis having major problems
in the state of Florida, and I want to talk
about that next. The double ACP is warning black
folks, LGBT folks and other minority groups don't
go to Florida. It's dangerous. Ron DeSantis
Florida is a very dangerous place. A very
interesting article from the Miami Herald says,
Hate inspired leadership and ACP joins other
groups in warning against travel to Florida. The
oldest civil rights group is cautioning travelers
reconsider visits to Florida as they join other
advocates in expressing distaste for the state's
openly hostile leadership.